hi I'm Ted with harry shearer retiring  I'm auditioning for any part I can get  in the Simpsons Smythe's release the  hounds excellent  hidey-ho neighbor okely-dokely named  Reno one of the great exchanges between  homer and Lisa but Dad I'm a vegetarian  I don't eat animals but Lisa animals are  so delicious there's the animal we get  bacon from the animal we can ham from  the animal we get sausage from dad  that's all the same animal oh sure Lisa  a magic animal that all the wonderful  foods come from Kang and kodos in one of  the great classic episodes when they run  for president I'm running for president  now and you know it's really tough  forward not backwards upwards not  downwards and always twirling twirling  for freedom I had been told many times I  have a face for radio and I have a face  for animation